[Música]
vocês sabiam que o brasil é o segundo
país com maior quantidade de habitantes
negros mundo disse no mundo
o primeiro é a nigéria né fica lá do
outro lado lá no continente africano é o
penna de 2017 é uma pesquisa feita pelo
ibge é ele indicou que 54 por cento por
cento da população brasileira ela se
reconhece como negra ou seja a guarda e
preta
eu fico feliz em ver isso é porque cada
vez mais isso indica que cada vez mais
pessoas bem sabe se valorizando vem
defendendo a sua negritude e eu fico
feliz em ver que a visão pejorativa que
muito dinheiro e disse mesmo mudando
também fico feliz em ver que negros
na verdade essa visão pejorativa né eu
tinha quando criança eu lembro que
quando criança não queria usar black
power
eu achava feia não tinha referência eu
ficava lá não vou usar só queria usar
raspada
hoje já fala até pra minha filha filho
não quer ter o cabelo cacheado daqui
power que realizar 13 anos a não ficar
bem linda e ela achava que lindo é e
hoje em dia ela gosta acho bonita que
feliz de ver negros de lugares que eu
não via antes né fazendo coisas que eles
não faziam antes atendo coisas que não
tinham antes
sabem né e vendo essas mudanças essa
situação é só me faz crer que a
comunidade ea a sociedade está mudando e
mudando para melhor
é claro que eu sei que apurou ser
otimista não vai ignorar o fato da
realidade que essa mudança
ainda é muito recente essa mudança ainda
está muito lenta porque ela deveria ser
né eu atribuo isso ao fato de que nós né
um ponto sociedade
a gente não vem combatendo o foco a a
questão fundamental que é o racismo o
racismo e e seus efeitos não só queria
de favela ela nasceu na favela da
kelson's no rio de janeiro na zona norte
do rio de janeiro
minha mãe teve seis filhos uma faleceu
não me chama clara da silva ela criou
sozinho esse de 5 cinco filhos né
a família nada convencional pelo menos
para quem não mora na favela e houve
coisas situações que aconteceram comigo
né
por ser preto por isso é favelado teve
uma que me marcou
estava dentro de um ônibus em copacabana
etapas vindo do trabalho não estava
encontrar com o amigo estava sentado de
ônibus estava na hora do rush
o ônibus parava em vários lugares e um
ponto de se que o ônibus parou
pode reparar pelas luzes que duas
viaturas da polícia estavam do lado no
ônibus não peguei olhei para o lado vi
que ele estava olhando para o céu estava
olhando eu peguei e falei pra ele também
tem tudo normal e quando o ônibus foi
sair do do ponto de ônibus né aquela via
as duas viaturas ligaram a sirene
uma foi para frente do do ônibus ea
outra foi para a parte de trás do ônibus
já me deu aquele ele bate a vender
aquele nervosismo e houve quatro
policiais entraram no ônibus na parte da
frente e dois ficaram na parte de trás
eu estava vendo que eles quatro
policiais veio na minha direção eu
fiquei nervoso código tinha 14 anos na
época jogando 14 15 anos e 11 mil para
revistar a bolsa peguei minha bolsa pra
ele pediu para levantar a camisa eu
peguei levantei minha camisa
e ele começou a perguntar aonde eu falei
torno de casa e está indo pra onde vão
encontrar um amigo e foi bastante
constrangedor para mim é isso que os
policiais estavam indo embora
eu sou uma voz de uma senhora né
gritando porque você só está revistando
ele não vem aqui me estava a revistaram
minha bolsa
ele veio pra senhora vi que ela era uma
sala branca e até fiquei assustado
quando foi de novo nada não vão sobrar
pra mim mas o policial pegou e olhou
para trás olhou pra ele não fez nada e
saiu simplesmente eles saíram e eu
fiquei ali né de tremendo com aquela
situação quem sentia aquela pressão toda
ela veio até mim perguntar se estava bem
como é que eu estava como estava se
sentindo e pedir desculpas e falou que
tava bem acompanhada
e aí eu pude perceber que a vergonha
dela não era pelo fato de os policiais
terem registado e sim pelo conjunto da
obra pela pela a ausência na empatia dos
outros passageiros que estavam no ônibus
pelo racismo evidente que eu tinha
passado naquele momento pela sociedade
vê que isso acontece todos os dias
diariamente e coloca isso lá porque
consideram isso como se fosse normal
colocar isso em uma prateleira isso é
natural
eu me lembro que depois daquilo daquela
situação fique pensando bastante falei
nossa só porque eu sou negro eu sou
bandido e aquilo com martelando na minha
cabeça né
você sabe que a cada 23 minutos
o negro negro é morto
sabia que sabia o que o estigma que
caras como eu carrego por aí ao fato
dele ser violentada
é o fato de ele morrer o pnad
ele divulgou recentemente que jovens
entre 15 a 19 anos têm três vezes mais
chance de ter uma morte violenta do que
um jovem branco
a gente está alarmante a gente tem que
parar de pensar sobre isso tá todo mundo
sabe que eu comecei a atuar o jovem eu
comecei fazendo teatro vou pôr a jeito
de fazer um teatro oito anos eu comecei
depois eu fiz um curta metragem chamado
palace 2 que passou na globo depois do
filme cidade de deus que é um filme que
pouco viajei o mundo que é uma
referência é pro cinema brasileiro no
exterior chegou a ser indicada prológica
depois eu fiz cidade dos homens efe mas
aí fiquei cinco anos na globo depois eu
fiz o filme cidade zona da série em seu
foi indicada para o emmy como melhor
ator por estados unidos brasil e estados
unidos combina para concorrer como
melhor ator não é
e aí eu vendo essa situação da situação
mudou de lá pra cá minha vida mudou
apraz essa oportunidade seguindo a minha
carreira consegui essa ascensão social
eu consegui mudar minha condição
financeira né eu fui vendo que aquela
situação que tinha passado uns anos
atrás
dentro daquele ônibus já não era tão
freqüente assim na minha vida acontecer
cada vez menos comigo mas porque é
porque eu era o cara primeira geada me
tornei um cara privilegiado
hoje em dia ainda assim vamos chamar de
seu sou casada tenho uma esposa tem uma
filha de 6 anos e sujeira também quando
fala vem cá e vamos ao shopping eu falei
tá eu coordenava o robô terá mesmo de
moletom e chinelos camiseta e fui ela
vai assim foi colocar o problema do
choque então gente ia passando assim
freqüentar lugares é que a maioria dos
livros não podem freqüentar a maioria
dos meus primos mesmo quem mora na
favela unidade não pode freqüentar
então eu fiquei me perguntando cara
então pra eu ser respeitado pela
sociedade para o pobre um negro ser
respeitada pela sociedade ele precisa
ser rico
ele precisa ter status martela na cabeça
não tem que ser assim e eu quando olho
para trás e vejo que eu saí da favela
vi que sabe aquele menininho que não
tinha perspectiva de vida é a não tinha
condições de ter outra e ter uma
profissão porque o nosso ensino precário
né eu lembro que a primeira profissão
que indicaram pra mim era pra ser
militar
esse era meu sonho tornar um sonho que
eu queria desejava aquilo que era a
única oportunidade que eu tinha porque
com 18 anos eu tenho que manter estável
tem que representar um traço a primeira
profissão o que a gente pensa em ter
filhos e em outros estados mas lá no rio
de janeiro
já a a minha geração de amigos essa era
a profissão porque ali a gente viu uma
oportunidade de ascender socialmente
dessa ascensão e até aquela estabilidade
financeira pelo menos por um ano
eu pego e vejo que jovens hoje em dia
jovens negros no tempo que não tenha
essa mesma oportunidade como ele não tem
essa ascensão social que eu tive como é
que eles vão conseguir pegar esse
elevador social e quando fala elevador
social eu não falo eu falo nos dois
sentidos no sentido literal no sentido
figurado é a gente vê vários relatos de
violência
sois que discriminam é outras pessoas
pedem pra impedem de que elas utilizem o
o o elevador social e colocar ela pra
usar o elevador de serviço geral pessoas
que passam por isso só que é negra e
pobre gente isso é crime
não pode acontecer isso então quando eu
falo olha para trás e fala também de
assessora social no sentido figurado
eu vejo que muitos é eu posso dar
exemplos porque o conheço vários amigos
tenho vários amigos
eu frequentei da comunidade da favela no
vivo e muitos ainda não têm perspectiva
de vida eles não vêem como compensação
social vem como pegar esse elevador
sabe-se elevador social isso porque eles
têm muitos e vencidos da vida
está a falta de dinheiro para poder tá
indo pro pro trabalho desde a falta de
dinheiro pra ir pro entrevista para
poder mudar a vida é desde o tiroteio
que impede o que ele vai estudar né
é é a falta do de um ensino de qualidade
isso tudo empecilho para isso ou seja
isso tudo interrompe
nessa seção ascensão social é engraçado
né
eu vejo que hoje em dia eu sou famoso as
pessoas venham possam andar em vários
lugares velho não ser discriminado
então precisa ser famoso né pra ser
tratado como uma pessoa se eu não fosse
famoso
de repente é se eu não fosse do brasil
até se estivesse andando assim será numa
conferência como essa acho que as
pessoas não iriam me olhavam estamos
olhando agora a artista ele pode então
sabe isso tem um peso e quando eu penso
que já vinham tendo essa oportunidade
a mulher de um caso que aconteceu tem 12
duas semanas atrás o menino jovem negro
direto de 14 anos de idade ele veio até
mim pedir um autógrafo e uma foto eu
peguei e falei com ele foi no condomínio
da minha sogra e aí ele veio me fez uma
pergunta que deixou até desconcertado né
perguntou como é que é ser famoso
como se explica isso é normal hoje em
dia né engraçado é sair do anonimato que
o edital
eu fiquei pensando por que você tá
perguntando isso aí eu ia falar porque
eu quero ser famoso que eu quero ganhar
dinheiro tá
o que você pensa em fazer na sua vida
pra você tá ganhando esse dia para você
se tornar famoso é não sei que só quero
ser famoso quer ganhar dinheiro e eu
fiquei aqui no pensamento é esse
para ele tanto faz tanto fez o que ele
fosse fazer aquilo fosse trazer uma
alegria uma satisfação pessoal né que a
gente busca muito isso satisfação do
nosso trabalho porque a gente levantar
todos
giba trabalho a gente pensa nisso então
aquilo me deixou sabe não desceu
eu fiquei olhando e eu não pude jogar
ele que provavelmente ele via que aquela
era a única forma que ele tinha de que a
sociedade passe a respeitar ele passa a
respeitar o jeito que ele estiver
sujeito que ele anda né eu eu acho que
pra gente é combater esse rácio essa
desigualdade social a gente não pode é
deixar com que o racismo se resolver
sozinho porque essa ideia já tenha mais
de 500 anos e não vem funcionando gente
é eu acho que o primeiro passo é a gente
a sociedade aceitar o racismo e ver que
a nossa sociedade
afundado em cima de financistas e
segundo passo a gente pegar esse racismo
pegar ele como referência para a gente
ver o que a gente não quer se tornar e
pegar ele para combater relações que a
gente não quer ter futuramente é o falo
isso porque eu penso na minha filha né e
o racismo racista ele não a pessoa não
nasce racista
ela é ensinada tem criança em casa assim
como eu tenho a seu filho que estejam
perto de você com certeza estão
observando que está falando
você tem que prestar bem atenção você
pai você professor você fala dele sala
de aula que a criança absorve tem que
prestar bastante atenção nas coisas que
elas estão vendo seja na internet
na internet a gente tem acesso a tudo
seja na internet seja na televisão e
filmes desenhos e até no parquinho de
várias relações alisson várias pessoas
têm que prestar atenção tem que prestar
atenção nisso tudo
eu posso falar com propriedade eu sou
negro já passei por isso que a gente não
combater o racismo
dessa forma honestamente de igual para
igual de frente para o brasil nunca
nunca ele vai atingir o potencial que
ele tem porque a desigualdade ea gente
tem entre negros e brancos é muito
grande é muito grande e eu falo que essa
luta tem que ser todos têm que lutar só
tem que ser preto ou branco a quem tem
dinheiro não tem dinheiro para que a
famosa para quem não é famoso tá porque
eu não acho justo eu tenho que me vestir
de branco para a sociedade né poder me
respeitar
[Aplausos]
[Música]